hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president biden holding his first solo
press conference since taking office
addressing immigration voting rights and
vowing to hold china accountable
for unfair trade practices and human
rights abuses former white house press
secretary
and fox news contributor kaylee mcinnady
and democratic strategist and co-host of
the five juan williams
break down the key moments republican
lawmakers are pushing back against a
pair of infrastructure proposals
from the biden administration which
aimed to fund clean energy priorities
including energy-efficient affordable
housing and electric vehicle charging
stations
fox news correspondent mark meredith
weighs in on the future of the solar
industry
and the process of converting solar
energy into electricity
plus commentary from jimmy fayla host of
fox across
america the fox news rundown is a daily
news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
martha mccallum i'm bill hemmer i'm
shannon breme and this
is the fox news rundown
friday march 26 2021 i'm jessica
rosenthal
president biden has held his first press
conference taking questions from
reporters including one
about why journalists have not been able
to see the border facilities
where hundreds of migrant children are
being kept it was a direct admission
that it's just too bad at this moment
to allow the american public to seize
others gave the president
and reporters high marks i think they
wanted it to be clear
that when it comes to joe biden that
they are willing
to press him on the critical issues of
the day
i'm chris foster some farmers in ohio
are making big bucks through solar
farming
letting energy companies use the land to
install solar panels to make electricity
not everyone thinks it's a good idea
they're worried that this is going to
negatively impact
farming for generations to come they're
worried that this land
basically being taken out by these solar
farms because they're producing solar
instead of crops
will make it impossible for them to be
able to lease more land to farm
that it's gonna drive food prices up we
speak with fox news correspondent mark
meredith
and i'm jimmy fella i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
president biden has held his first press
conference on his 64th day in office
president obama had his within a few
weeks and president trump's first formal
presser was in less than a month
no one asked why it had taken so long
but president biden began his press
conference by saying
he's been focused on the pandemic now
today i'm setting a second goal
and that is we will by my 100th day in
office
have administered 200 million shots
when it came time for questions there
were ten our own peter ducey was not
among them
the questions focused on things like the
border the filibuster
china when asked if he was willing to
commit to transparency
to letting reporters be allowed in to
see border facilities holding children
he responded i will commit when my plan
very shortly is underway to let you have
access to not just them but
other facilities as well on the
filibuster he said he supported a
talking filibuster but said he agreed
with president obama
that the filibuster is a relic of jim
crow we're we're going to get a lot done
and if we have to if there's complete
lockdown and chaos as a consequence of
the filibuster then
we'll have to go beyond what i'm talking
about when asked if he planned to run
for re-election
he said that is his expectation but he
was then asked why he hadn't set up a
re-election committee like his
predecessor
president trump had done at this point
he said he missed his predecessor
he was then asked if he expects he'll
run against president trump in 2024
oh come on i don't even think about i
don't have i have no idea
i have no idea what it'll be a
republican party biden will be 82 in
2024.
among a handful of foreign policy
questions he gave a long answer on china
saying he believes he may have spent
more time with chinese president xi
jinping
than any other world leader and that he
plans to commit more money to science
and research to compete with the chinese
he said some republican state efforts to
reform elections
is pernicious and that he will fight to
make recently passed house legislation
on
national election reform law there was a
very low bar
for president biden there's no doubt
about that kaylee mcinadie was white
house spokeswoman under president trump
and is a fox news contributor i think
you know the media is essentially saying
that he passed that very low bar
when in fact if you analyze what he said
he did not pass that bar
uh you know for instance on the issue of
immigration
uh you know he said that the vast
majority of those coming to the border
are being turned away we have an axios
report
saying uh in fact 87 of families are
being let in and having their cases
adjudicated in the country so
issues like that which would not be so
gratuitous in a trump administration it
would have been called a lie
are just simply overlooked uh in today's
mainstream media
you've had to deal with your fair share
of reporters asking questions
how do you think reporters did there
there were some reporters uh that rose
to the occasion kristen welker
being one uh she asked a very good
question about transparency and then she
followed up after that question
uh and the question prior to her as well
uh from abc
similarly uh kind of put president biden
in a spot on immigration
uh but you know one thing i wish i would
have seen more is all of the reporters
to ask tough questions unlike
caitlyn collins who asked he's going to
run for re-election
uh but didn't come with follow-ups and
you kind of missed the caustic vitriolic
follow-up she got in the
trump era which is a good thing because
i don't think that that's particularly
helpful to the american people
but it is a noted contrast between the
two administrations
there were plenty of references to his
predecessor
by president biden himself he said he
missed his predecessor when asked
you know why he hadn't set up a
re-election committee like trump had at
this point
and when asked if um he expected he'd be
running against president trump
he said who knows if there will even be
a republican party by then
what was your reaction to that yeah
those are not the words of a great
uniter
uh and in fact that came after he took
another swipe at the republican party
saying that the republican party was the
party of division when in fact it was
uh president joe biden who called
republicans into the oval office
acted as if he cared about their coveted
relief plans or compromises and then
essentially steamrolled them and moved
forward with only democrat
votes so i can assure him there will be
a republican party
it will be a very robust one uh of
course noting the great games that were
made in the senate and in the house in
the previous election
president trump used to talk about his
relationship with leaders like xi
jinping of china
president biden said he spent quite a
bit of time with xi jinping but he he
criticized
president trump for not calling out
china on human rights abuses
um you know saying that we lose
legitimacy around the world when we walk
away from values like that what did you
think of that comparison
um that that's absolute insanity maybe
he wasn't paying attention but i
continually when i was at the podium
always talked about um the uyghurs and
the genocide being committed against
them and the xinjiang province
those atrocities that we were
unmistakable where we stood the state
department as well
um it was actually president biden press
secretary in her first
press conference uh that did not note
right away unequivocally without
hesitancy
uh that indeed it was a genocide later
the uh talking points evolved
and they did in fact acknowledge it and
i think the fighting secretary of state
had acknowledged it so perhaps she was
not familiar that he had but
my point would be it seems to be their
their administration that
certainly out of the gate stumbled on on
the issue of human rights in china
and what did you make of what um
president biden said about the
filibuster
saying he agreed with president obama
that it was a relic of the jim crow era
after saying that he would support a
talking filibuster the way it was when
he was in the senate
do you think that the filibuster is on
its way out or in real danger
it certainly is and it seems to have
become a relic of jim crow when it was
no longer convenient for joe biden
and the democrats um you know it's
interesting that he takes that home when
in fact just you know a few years prior
he was defending it ardently
um as was his entire party during the
trump administration so
it's it's a glaring hypocrisy that i
think people are well aware of
uh but it certainly seems vulnerable to
filibuster no doubt
when asked about immigration and the
surge especially of minors the president
said he should be flattered that they're
coming if they think
that he's a nice guy but that surges
happen regardless of
who is in office just as one happened
under president trump
um and then he said that president
trump's policies had a negative impact
on law and human dignity and he
that he does not apologize for rolling
back remain in mexico or taking children
from parents
my understanding is while the president
has rolled back some of
president trump's immigration policies
um that unfortunate
situation in which parents were taken
from their children was
was changed during the trump
administration it was changed that's
right and we know that that initially
happened uh because of something not to
get too um
you know deep in the weeds here because
of something called the flora settlement
agreement that unfortunately
led to that uh but president trump
you're right undid it but i can tell you
what is not humane is incentivizing
children to cross the border
uh leave their parents because they're
accepting kids who arrive alone uh be
the victims of coyotes
uh god forbid sex abuse and physical
abuse that we know these kids are
oftentimes subjected to that is not
humane it's double down
on that policy of opening our arms to uh
kids who arrive alone just incentivizes
that
so it was a ridiculous statement um by
president biden
finally what did you make of his answer
on transparency at the border that
he needs to implement his plan first
before giving
reporters access i know there was a
follow-up to that from kristen walker
but
no one else really said hey why aren't
we being allowed in why do you need your
plan to be rolled out first
exactly and i think to me that that was
the biggest
shock and take away from the press
conferences to me when i heard that it's
essentially an admission that
it is so inhumane and overcrowded and so
uh desperate and and despicable
conditions down there that
he has to roll out his plan before he
could ever let the cameras then to me it
was a direct admission that it's just
too bad at this moment
to allow the american public to see so
that to me was
the biggest takeaway and one of the most
important moments of the press
conference
but some felt president biden's answer
was sufficient there
juan williams is a host on the five
clearly reporters want
access to these facilities where the
young people are being
held at the moment but what the ans the
reason the answer
was effective i think from the media
perspective from my perspective
is that there was an admission here that
this is a process in flux that things
are not
finalized that they are trying to not
only honor
america's first amendment values of
press freedoms transparency and access
but also
honor what's going on with these young
people that people do have some right to
privacy in these difficult situations
and that
the admission was that the byte
administration is still trying to get
things right
but according to the president at the
press conference they're going to get
things right quickly and that access
will be granted so it didn't seem like
an
unreasonable statement well let me ask
you about the filibuster it does require
60 votes in the senate in order to bring
a vote to the floor
and the president said he was in favor
it sounded like a talking filibuster
to reduce the abuse of the filibuster
but when asked if he agreed with former
president obama that it was a relic of a
jim crow era he said
yes and he also said if there are too
many you know
i guess lockdowns was the word in terms
of debate then we'll have to go beyond
what i'm
talking about meaning a talking
filibuster might not even be enough
it sounds like he may want to get rid of
the filibuster well it sure
sounded like he was open to that idea
but i think the emphasis from the
president
at the press conference was the talking
filibuster would be allowed that in
other words you would diminish the idea
that anybody can just pick up the phone
and say they're doing a filibuster and
that it would therefore
block legislation one of the key points
that he made on this was
that the filibuster is being abused and
from the white house perspective and
actually from democrats on capitol hill
as from their perspective as well what
they all cite
is that over the last 20 years or so
what we've seen is hundreds of use
of the filibuster annually whereas
prior to that it was something that was
done once a year
and it wasn't done to stop legislation
but simply to slow things down and allow
for more
debate even as the president was talking
about his next major legislative
initiative which is you know build back
better and putting trillions of dollars
into infrastructure
he was again talking about the need to
avoid the filibuster
juan he called voting laws that some
republicans are trying to pass in states
despicable
uh he said that uh they make jim crow
look like jim eagle i think was the was
the word
yes exactly those opposed to the house
bill that would reform voting laws say
you know voting rules should really be
set up by the states and and allow what
works for
individual states but it sounds like
this president
wants this house bill to pass and to
have more i guess
uniformity or agreement among states
about how voting should work
well i think this is a problem for the
president because i don't think there's
any question that the founding fathers
and the constitution uh
and the way we do business even today is
all about states
being the determinators of how elections
are
run it's up to the states i mean you
think back to the controversial last
election
it was having state electors send their
decisions to congress
to be certified the problem here is that
we still have some people
especially on the republican side who
holy opinion that
maybe the election was stolen maybe
there was some fraud involved and they
are cracking down in terms of
you know early voting weekend voting
hours of voting and that's now
becoming something of a rage on the
republican side
in states that are controlled by
republican legislatures
and so you're seeing a response coming
from the democrats
in washington finally juan um this was
obviously a markedly different press
conference than we have seen for the
past four years
with the prior president i'm wondering
how you think
reporters did i think they did great uh
you know that
as i said i think part of this press
conference was really about
the critics when i say the critics here
i'm saying the republican party in the
aftermath of donald trump
i think on the one hand they were they
were trying to make sure that
they were as aggressive with biden as
they had been with trump
uh to make sure that people who are
trump supporters wouldn't say oh look at
the press they're just laid down
for joe biden or secondly i think they
wanted it to be clear
that when it comes to joe biden that
they are willing to press him on the
critical issues
of the day and obviously that was
immigration that was guns
uh and that was coveted i think they
covered all those issues
juan williams thank you so much for your
time jessica my pleasure i love doing it
thank you for having
[Music]
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
part of president biden's infrastructure
plan includes investment through tax
credits and renewable energy like solar
already utility companies are buying
more of it and scientists are working to
make it cheaper and more efficient
although solar panels have to be
installed someplace and energy companies
are investing millions in solar farms
on what has been actual farm land what
we're looking at really is the future of
what the solar industry wants to be
fox news correspondent mark meredith's
been speaking with solar company
executives
and farmers leasing land to them in
southwestern ohio
they are taking out hundreds and
hundreds if not thousands of acres of
farmland
and they're setting up rows and rows of
solar panels and really it looks like
something out of a science fiction movie
because you just have these uh these
solar panels aimed towards the sun that
rotate throughout the day
and they are in these farmlands because
it's flat it's uh easy land for them to
build on
and then they can easily hook these
panels up into the uh
the grid the electrical grid that's
nearby but what's interesting is that
this energy is not what's going to be
sent to the neighboring town this is
energy that's going to be used hundreds
of miles away and instead of it just
being you know a few solar panels here
or there like we're used to seeing on
rooftops instead
they're doing this these mass facilities
because they want to generate
so much power and the other factor that
has really just exploded in all of this
is that there is so much competition not
only for
you know the ability to create this kind
of industry energy i should say
but because they want to be able to have
as much
solar output as possible so they need a
lot of farmland to do it
i mean there are before we get into the
economic and environmental
benefits there are complaints with the
idea with these solar farms popping up
that there's these ugly blights
on what used to be a pretty open field
or farmland or do they strike you as an
eyesore if you live nearby would it
bother you i know i mean i'm a pretty
low-key guy but i guarantee you my wife
would not want to live anywhere near any
of these things uh this
they are massive they are uh you know
it's not just one or two panels
covered by shrubs i mean you would drive
by and you'd say what is that it looks
like the death star
it is a massive um field that is taking
over here
however where they are out is is pretty
rural i mean you don't have you know of
you know big neighborhoods or you know
an office park or anything like that
they are in farming communities but for
the folks that live out here they you
know they're not used to to that kind of
stuff they're used to corn they're used
to soybeans and cattle
it's not every day you see a solar farms
out there but the big benefit
for these farmers that lease the land
that give their i mean they're getting
paid handsomely to do this
but you can imagine if you know across
the street you've decided not to do it
you're now looking at uh you know at
solar panels i would imagine there would
be a few
people that would not be thrilled with
that but chris here's the other thing
it's not necessarily just the view that
people are unhappy about they're worried
that this is going to negatively impact
farming for generations to come they're
worried that this land
basically being taken out by these solar
farms because they're producing solar
instead of crops
will make it uh impossible for them to
be able to lease more land to farm
that it's going to drive food prices up
that there's not going to be
the same generational output that we
have seen from years
past yeah i mean what happens to the
land as farmland if this technology say
it never really catches on
uh or eventually moves on to something
else that's
that's a great point because the solar
companies they are leasing out farmland
and hundreds of acres of this
for 30 years so they are making an
investment they say that they want to
take up this land they're leasing not
buying
for most cases for 30 years and the
solar companies told us
yes that at the end of the day 30 years
from now this land will basically be
returned that they'll be able to
you know bring it back to the farm
conditions that they were that they'll
take the panels out and plant
there are some farmers that are
skeptical that that would happen you
know a lot can change between the next
three days let alone 30 years from now
and there is that some people have told
us they're worried that if these solar
farms were to go out of business let's
say that the solar technology
is not the next big thing that something
else happens maybe these would be left
there to decay
the solar companies we spoke with push
back against that pretty hard saying
that they have a way to get this cleaned
up
but you also have to wonder about the
farmland you know for 30 years you don't
grow anything
30 years you have a bunch of panels
covering this ground
i can't imagine that you know corn is
just gonna you know pop back
up in the year after uh but of course a
lot can change between now and then
yeah i mean a lot of these farmers i'm
sure are saying look it's my land to do
with what i want maybe i'm not farming
soybeans but
i'm making a profit and not only that
because like you said these leases are
locked in
you're now not worried about weather or
other natural disasters or
demand or trade war you have this
predictable exactly i mean farming is
not
yeah you're right farming is not an easy
industry anybody who's done it will tell
you that
and you know basically you're being
offered for the next 30 years guaranteed
income you would imagine for a lot of
people
that's pretty hard to turn down and it's
not just a few bucks i mean people are
making serious money
by leasing out their farmland because
there's also competition for the land
these solar companies are not just
putting them anywhere they need a
specific type of terrain
they want to do it areas that are hooked
up to the electrical grid where we are
in southwest ohio
they can send this energy out to
illinois to new jersey
they're able to really connect it and
send it out in places that uh
need more output at the risk of sounding
very rudimentary here have you learned
much about how
these farms actually collect and
distribute solar power and we know it's
you know energy from the sun
but how is that converted to electricity
the way that these solar panels
are set up in row after row they're uh
basically collecting that energy and
then
it's up converted uh into a in a box and
then transferred underground
into another system that moves it into
the power grid it is uh
it's not like you'll see you know if it
was a uh you know a coal fire plant
where you'll see the uh
the stuff coming out at night i mean you
would never notice it um unless
except if you were to see the panels
themselves they hide a lot of the wiring
underground um and at least these are
new facilities right they're using new
technology
it's not as uh you know uh distracting
as it may have been you know 20 30 years
ago
in terms of of what's there but to your
point for these
solar farms they are massive it's not
one or two panels
thousands and thousands of panels so if
you are
out there you can't help but look at it
it's uh it is noticeable it doesn't
matter how many uh trees or shrubs are
planted
you will definitely notice them out
there how does it work is this solar
energy companies selling to utilities or
utilities setting
this up for themselves or what these are
uh solar cup
these are a few different things here
the energy company that we spoke with
yesterday is a canadian
company called energex and they
basically are able to offer this out to
companies that have been asking for
green energy you know a lot of companies
out there are making uh
commitments that they want to be
sustainable with uh clean power
by exa next year or in a certain amount
of time so they are working with those i
understand that there's some of these
other solar farms that are working to
put output
to different state electrical grids i
mean we all remember what happened with
texas with the storm uh you know a few
weeks ago
and you would imagine that there's going
to be more of a demand for uh you know a
stronger energy grid while there's a lot
of people questioning
what happened in texas and what needs to
happen going forward
these uh companies energy companies see
a big future in solar and that's why
they continue to make this investment
they also told us that the uh what it
costs to get the output of energy they
are doing
has gone down significantly so what
would cost
you know uh let's say a dollar you know
10 years ago is now only costing 10
cents
so for them it makes much more sense to
invest in solar now because they see the
prices only going down in the future
and allows them to also make the meet
the commitment that many places want for
clean energy
yeah i mean a criticism of solar and
wind for that matter in the past that it
takes a lot of energy and a lot of money
just to set up to set up and maintain
this and maybe you had to spend
you know a dollar twenty to get it on
making this up but a dollar twenty to
get a dollars worth of electricity and
now you've said those prices have just
dropped so much where it is competitive
with coal for example absolutely i mean
that's where these
these companies are investing millions
and millions of dollars it'd be hard to
believe that they would invest it if
they didn't see a future in it
but to these uh you know these other
people's concerns you know who's to say
that solar
is going to be the you know guaranteed
energy of the future i mean there
certainly has been so many rapid
advancements in technology
you could imagine that there would be
something else that would be competing
along with it but these uh these solar
companies do see an opportunity here and
with cost being what they are now that
they've gone down so much they're able
to say
we can make this worth our wall and also
make it worth the while of the farmers
that we're leasing land from
but these other farmers that are saying
no to this also just fear
you know what's to say that they don't
go out of business and then what do you
do i mean you've got these solar panels
now
in your yard and it's you know if a
business goes out of business
they're not just going to come by and
pick them up so there has been some
concern of that but nobody knows for
sure what the future is going to bring
yeah it's not like you can just leave
these out with the recycling i mean
there's got to be a process to
you know to get rid of this stuff now my
understanding is that president biden's
infrastructure plan is going to include
some pretty nice tax breaks for
renewables is that
is that factoring into this boom the
solar industry certainly sees a lot of
enthusiasm coming out of the white house
and they've told us that before that
they really see this as a chance to
grow their industry they felt that
perhaps the last four years they weren't
getting the support
they needed uh to really grow what they
wanted to do
it's still early in the administration i
mean obviously we'll have to see what
congress comes up with with this
infrastructure bill the president is
going to be
you know speaking a lot more to that
within the weeks ahead
but the solar industry what we're seeing
at least here is not waiting for the
government to say
this is the route we want to go they see
this as a private enterprise
able to uh you know create a marketplace
for this yeah and for all the
you know concerns of people in coal and
oil those industries and those
communities
were saying well they might be saying
well geez now president biden is
is picking winners and losers and we're
the losers here but if that
if the technology is getting that much
better and that much cheaper
this just could be natural selection and
you'd be amazed where we are in
southwest ohio i have seen trump flags
everywhere you would never think that
the election was last november i mean
this
is uh as pretty much solid red as you
can imagine these
are conservative voters by and large but
they also say
you know with the money that is being
offered and you know when they they say
this is
what we're being offered how do we you
know turn this away i mean this is
guaranteed income for
30 years you would imagine for a lot of
these people money talks
well mark i'm going to end with this
instead of instead of a red state maybe
ohio's turning into a green state how do
you like that
how do you like them apples yeah it's
still the ohio state
that's for sure the other
yep thank you mark uh mark mark meredith
and mount oreb ohio thanks for coming on
[Music]
mark
[Applause]
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcast.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
the historic theaters of broadway have
been silent for more than a year
closed when new york city became the u.s
epicenter of the pandemic
but now there's a plan to bring those
stages back to life
mayor bill de blasio says the city will
set up dedicated vaccination sites
specifically for the theater community
and the theater industry it will be
staffed by workers from the theater
industry
and there's also a plan for a mobile
unit to serve off-broadway theaters
as well as testing sites at or near
theaters
there are still a lot of things to be
worked out and full-scale plays and
musicals aren't expected to open again
until after labor day
but for theater-starved crowds and
tourists who plan trips to the city that
include a broadway experience
that's good news in new york tanya j
powers
fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fallon
what's on your mind so new york governor
andrew cuomo is being accused of getting
priority coveted testing for his family
and friends
and i know what you're thinking wow
that's shocking i can't believe
cuomo has friends the crazy part is that
for any other politician this is a
monster scandal but this will be lucky
to crack the top five with a dirt bag
like cuomo the love gov is being accused
of harassing eight women
covering up fifteen thousand nursing
home deaths and threatening a democratic
lawmaker who refused to defend him
letting his family cut the coveted test
line is like oj double
parking at nicole's house yes cuomo is a
me first garbage guy who's the worst
thing about politics
arrogant ignorant and shameless but i
can't get too mad about this because
let's be honest
if any of us were in charge of the
government we'd be hooking up our
families with special covet options too
maybe not all of them but at least the
cool ones congrats to andrew cuomo's
pals on their special treatment it's
nice to know that garth brooks isn't the
only one
with friends in low places i'm jimmy
fallon
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
hey it's brett larsen inviting you to
download and listen to the new daily fox
on tech podcast
there's part of a colorful late 90s imac
on mars
it's an idea that seems a lot like
kickstarter called build it subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes